Канцлер в Альпах -
Шольц виступає за нову глобалізацію
Вручення Міжнародної премії імені Карла Великого -
«наймужнішим жінкам Європи»
Концерт у Лондоні -
цифрові аватари гурту ABBA на сцені
В ефірі «heute journal»
з Гайнцом Вольфом та Марієттою Сломкою.
Доброго вечора.
Ситуація на Донбасі залишається
складною для українських військових.
Терміново необхідна допомога.
І, звичайно, Німеччина знову в центрі уваги -
одна з найбільших промислово розвинених країн
з одним із найбільших оборонно-промислових комплексів,
велика європейська держава, яка має
особливо тісні відносини із Росією.
Ці чинники і реакція на війну,
яку більшість вважає нерішучою,
поставили зовнішню політику Німеччини
у незручне становище.
В Україні, Східній Європі, країнах Балтії
зараз відкрито говорять про втрату довіри до Німеччини.
На тлі цих подій сьогодні у Давосі
виступив канцлер Німеччини.
Анна Ґеллінек з репортажем.
Можливо, лише випадковий збіг
у датах зустрічей,
а втім символічно,
що канцлер Німеччини прибуває на
Всесвітній економічний форум останнім.
На 5-денній зустрічі економічної,
фінансової та політичної еліти
тема війни в Україні була основною,
як і здогадки, як саме тлумачити
комунікацію уряду Німеччини щодо постачання озброєння.
Шольц поводиться так,
ніби не існує дискусій
про зволікання Німеччини у постачання зброї,
а натомість фокусується на Путіні.
Наша мета - чітко зрозуміла:
Путін не має виграти свою війну
і я переконаний,
що він її не виграє.
Наразі йому не вдалося досягнути жодної
зі своїх стратегічних цілей.
Україна прибула з великою делегацією
до швейцарських гір
і віртуозно зіграла на форумі у Давосі.
Відеоконференція з президентом України,
емоційні виступи братів Кличків.
«Вишенькою на торті» стала зустріч
близько 50 керівників міжнародних компаній
з українськими представниками,
включно з прем'єрміністром та міністром закордонних справ.
Мова йшла про відбудову країни.
Міністр закордонних справ Кулеба заявив,
що більше не хоче говорити про постачання зброї,
однак без цього не обійшлося.
Зараз ми вже зрозуміли, що Німеччина
не візьме на себе провідну роль
у постачанні зброї,
однак зрозуміло і те,
що без важкого озброєння
нас вбиватимуть.
Олаф Шольц у своєму виступі
намагався привернути увагу
до актуальних тем, як-от світова економіка,
ланцюжки постачань, глобалізація.
Звісно, критика Китаю через ставлення до уйгурів,
яке ﻿порушує права людини.
Однак про відмову від глобалізації не йдеться.
Я скажу абсолютно чітко,
деглобалізація – це глухий кут.
Вона не спрацює.
Заклик «в майбутньому ставити європейські
цінності вище прибутку»
затих і лишився майже не почутим
в коридорах конгрес-центру у Давосі.
Очільник компанії, яка заробляє великі гроші у Китаї,
покладається на «принцип надії».
Торгівля, комунікація, діяльність в інших країнах
дають нам можливість
сприяти їхньому руху в цьому напрямку.
Китай став більш відкритим,
це хвилеподібна тенденція,
тому Китай знову відкриється.
Позбавлення упевненості
в старому звичному світогляді
схвилювало учасників цьогорічного форуму в Давосі.
Ситуація у світі - складніша, ніж будь-коли,
її вирішення - також проблема.
Канцлер Німеччини прибув пізно,
але можливо це лише випадковий збіг
у датах зустрічей.
Анно Ґеллінек, як сприйняли промову Шольца?
Очевидно, він не сказав особливо нічого нового.
Так, Олаф Шольц у своїй промові створив великий «місток»
від України, потім зміна клімату
і аж до саміту G7 наступного місяця у Німеччині.
На мою думку, він втратив шанс
пояснити свою політику
міжнародній публіці, а також
делегації з України.
Ми розмовляли тут з багатьма учасниками форуму
і багато хто дивувався,
що така велика, важлива країна як Німеччина
так сухо і хаотично говорить
про постачання озброєння.
Сьогодні від Олафа Шольца очікували
чітких заяв,
але вони не прозвучали.
Він одразу проігнорував цю тему.
Шольц сказав, що Німеччина постачає озброєння,
зокрема і важку зброю
і що на Німеччину можна покластися.
Східна Європа гучно критикує Німеччину.
Міністр оборони Латвії у зв'язку з війною в Україні
нещодавно сказав,
що довіра до Німеччини впала майже до нуля.
Міністр закордонних справ України висловив схожу думку,
це прозвучало так, наче Німеччину «списали з рахунків»?
І так, і ні.
Дійсно, щодо постачання зброї
також і на рівні Європи
Німеччину вже не сприймають серйозно.
Міністр закордонних справ України сказав,
що це такий собі спортивний інтерес,
аби побачити, чим це все обернеться.
Щодо іншої ключової теми, відбудови України, то
тут німці не зайняли «лаву запасних».
Україна розраховує на
потужну фінансову могутність Німеччини
і на німецькі компанії.
Дякую, Анно Ґелінек.
Україна бореться за свою незалежність
і за те, аби вижити.
Через війну в Україні стурбовані
й інші країни, які побоюються,
що вони можуть стати наступними жертвами.
Грузія, Молдова.
Разом з Україною хвилюється
також демократичний рух у Білорусі.
Він був зацькований
жорстокою диктатурою Лукашенка,
однак ще досі існує.
Деякі білоруси зараз навіть воюють
разом з українськими військовими.
Три жінки,
які стали обличчям опозиції у Білорусі,
говорять і зараз.
Принаймні Світлана Тихановська і Вероніка Цепкало,
які знайшли політичний притулок за межами Білорусі.
Третя, Марія Колесникова, досі у в'язниці.
Усі троє отримали сьогодні
Міжнародну премію імені Карла Великого.
Детальніше - Єна Квон.
#Звільніть Колесникову -
цей заклик не дає про неї забути.
Колесникова - єдина, хто не може
отримати премію особисто
на церемонії нагородження в ратуші Аахена.
За словами політичної діячки опозиції Білорусі
Світлани Тихановської,
ця нагорода - також під знаком війни в Україні.
Коли почалася війна,
багато чого змінилося для громадян Білорусі
і для нашої боротьби.
Тепер ми повинні боротися з
диктатурою, тиранією не лише у Білорусі,
але й воювати на боці України.
Ми повинні захищати Україну,
бо наші долі пов'язані одна з одною.
Вони стали найвідомішими обличчями,
людьми, які організовували
масові протести проти Лукашенка
попри державне свавілля авторитарного режиму.
Тихановська, яка стала переможцем
в суперечливих виборах 2020 року,
зараз у вигнанні як політична біженка
разом з подругою Веронікою Цепкало.
Марія Колеснікова, однак, залишилася
і була засуджена до 11 років колонії.
З в'язниці у Мінську вона шле знак «сердечка»,
який донині є її візитною карткою.
На вручення Міжнародної премії Карла Великого
до Аахену прибула її сестра.
Я знаю, що моїй сестрі
у в'язниці нелегко.
Вона знаходиться там вже майже 20 місяців,
але залишається сильною.
Батько Олександр Колесніков
також пишається Машею,
як він називає свою дочку.
Його останній візит до в'язниці
був кілька місяців тому
і нагадує йому, як сильно він сумує за дочкою.
Було приємно відчути присутність Маші.
Найбільше мене зворушив
поцілунок через скло.
Я досі відчуваю обійми, яких так і не було.
Листи - єдиний засіб спілкування,
який у нас залишився.
Це неймовірна історія, яка надихає людей
за межами Білорусі.
Сьогодні в Аахені міністерка закордонних справ
Анналена Бербок виступає з хвалебною промовою,
віддаючи належне мужності трьох жінок.
Ваша мужність не може бути замкнена.
Ідея свободи не може бути вигнана.
Три білоруські жінки як взірець для багатьох,
які сьогодні виступають за мир в Європі.
Зараз новини починаються з
військових подій в Україні.
Згідно з українськими даними,
російські війська атакували
понад 40 міст на Донбасі,
загрожуючи останньому основному шляху евакуації
цивільного населення зі Сходу України.
Президент України Зеленський заявив,
що російські солдати
«значно переважають» українські війська
в деяких частинах на Сході.
В Луганській області Сєвєродонецьк і Лисичанськ,
очевидно, є останніми великими містами,
які ще утримуються українськими військовими.
За словами держсекретаря Блінкена, уряд США,
попри війну Путіна в Україні,
залишається зосередженим на
найбільшому довгостроковому виклику
для міжнародного порядку
і цей виклик походить від
Китайської Народної Республіки.
У програмній промові,
присвяченій політиці Китаю,
Блінкен сказав, що Китай має намір
переформатувати міжнародний порядок,
для чого дедалі більше розвиває
свою економічну, дипломатичну,
військову та технологічну міць.
Водночас Блінкен запевнив,
що США не шукають конфлікту.
Польський парламент вирішив скасувати
спірну дисциплінарну палату Верховного Суду.
Комісія ЄС вважала дисциплінарну палату загрозою
незалежності суддів та вимагала її розпуску.
Рішення парламенту, ймовірно,
стане темою візиту до Польщі
голови Єврокомісії Урсули фон дер Ляєн,
запланованого на наступний тиждень.
У Берліні розпочалася дводенна зустріч
міністрів енергетики,
навколишнього середовища та клімату країн G7.
Наразі у G7 головує Німеччина.
Міністр економіки та захисту клімату Німеччини Габек
попереджав про недопустимість
протиставлення кліматичної та енергетичної кризи.
Обидві кризи повинні вирішуватися одночасно.
Міністерка охорони навколишнього середовища
Штеффі Лемке заявила, що
немає ані часу, ані ресурсів,
щоб вирішувати кризи одна за одною.
А тепер до новин спорту.
Збірна Німеччини з хокею не змогла
обіграти команду Чехії
у чвертьфіналі на чемпіонаті світу в Гельсінки.
Команда тренера
Тоні Седерхольма програла з рахунком 4:1.
Тепер прогноз погоди на найближчі дні.
Завтра очікується вітряна,
частково штормова погода,
місцями з грозами на півночі
та зливами на сході.
На інших територіях сухо - від 16° до 23°.
Найближчими днями буде
переважно прохолодно зі зливами,
але на півдні здебільшого сухо.
Температура становитиме від 12° до 21°.
Якщо на вечірці не вдається відірватися по повній -
гурт ABBA в поміч.
Принаймні, це працює від мого покоління і далі.
Але будьте обережні:
поки міленіали відвертаються з поблажливими усмішками -
ця вже зовсім не молода четвірка
щойно показала майже найбільш футуристичний концерт,
який тільки можна собі уявити.
Цифрова подорож у часі
назад у 1970-ті роки, з «аббатарами».
Відразу не так легко уявити,
але Андреас Штамм покаже нам,
як це виглядає.
Сьогодні прем'єра в Лондоні.
Шведське королівське подружжя
в лондонському Іст-Енді -
знак чогось значущого.
Це фантастично, стільки поколінь,
всі люблять ABBA.
Шанувальники з усього світу
чекають на появу гурту.
Їх почули ― вперше за десятиліття
квартет виступає єдиним складом.
Для подорожі в часі у власне минуле.
Ми щасливі знову бути і працювати разом.
Ніби повертаємось додому.
Дорогою сюди в машині було таке відчуття,
ніби ми знову їдемо на концерт.
Я дуже нервую і
дуже схвильована.
І я ще не бачила цього.
Йдеться про музичне відродження.
* пісня гурту ABBA «SOS» *
Перший концерт за 40 років.
Оригінальні голоси.
Їхні рухи.
Гурт ABBA.
Все тільки завдяки світлу.
Герої поп-музики 1970-х
збережені як голограми.
Це створює ілюзію справжнього концерту.
Я бачив людей на репетиціях,
які повністю повірили у справжність виступу.
Вони «уклали» таку собі угоду з голограмами:
так, я хочу вірити, що ABBA справді тут.
Півтори години шоу.
Що є справжнім, а що ні - складно розрізнити.
Команда з майже 1000 осіб витратила 5 років
на відродження «аббатарів».
Цифрова проєкція гурту 1979 року.
За допомогою 160 камер
концертні пісні знімали
разом з учасниками гурту протягом кількох тижнів.
Потім оцифровували, омолоджували
та об'єднували в одне шоу,
щоб повернути емоції.
Продано 400 мільйонів альбомів.
* пісня гурту ABBA «Super Trouper» *
Четверо веселих шведів з Поп-Олімпу.
У сльозах до кінця - це було на початку 1980-х.
Гурт розпався.
Кінець шлюбу ― подружжя розлучається.
Це було в особистому житті.
У музичному житті вони успішно повернулися
минулої осені з альбомом Voyage.
Але учасники гурту більше не хочуть гастролювати.
Замість цього можна розібрати
та побудувати зал в іншому місці,
якщо шоу «Завжди молоді» стане
касовим хітом в Лондоні.
«Thank you for the music» - назва пісні ABBA,
яку просто необхідно тут згадати.
На сьогодні це все,
продовження з Маркусом Ланцом.
Наступний випуск «heute Xpress»
буде близько опівночі.
До завтра, до побачення.